welcome everybody we are back for
another business QA while I play league
of legends and answer your questions i'm
about to get in game I've got my usual
co-host Rishi Cup TV Rishi welcome
aboard whoa it's friday yay happy Friday
everybody what's in the cup you know I
uh I wanted to have coffee in my cup
this morning but I've got a cup of water
only because I don't know if you know
this Evan I can only eat I can only
drink one cup of coffee a day generally
and I'm going to be doing that with my
my communities is today at one for my
livestreams I'm going to be drinking my
cup of coffee with them so I have water
it's kind of boring maybe maybe you
gotta like water down the coffee so you
can have double the coffee you know I
know you know what it is it's actually
it's not the coffee I like my coffee
like this week which means it's got
sugar in it and so for me to have two
cups of sugar it messes me up well maybe
we need to find a sweet version with
less calories or something so you can
double up if we can if we can double up
on the Rishi coffee intake that my place
more goodness in the world gets a bra
sweetener or agave nectar or oh oh
that's so awful my mom recently said why
don't you start putting honey in your
coffee I'm like oh if that is that's
what it has to come to I'll stop there's
a solution there's a solution Rishi I
think we need to dive deeper on it I
feel like jay is already on the case
with the rising ideas good so that
that's great because I have literally
searched high and low for alternatives
but like nothing i mean you know all of
the natural I've tried all the natural
sweeteners all the healthy so called
sugar replacements and like it just does
it she's not the same
detective calm that talked about a
naturally sweet coffee so it's not sweet
it's it's just kind of coffee is
interesting and what kind of coffee is
it he's looking it up or you can do the
louis roofing just go black intelligence
your call okay I think I've heard of
that but I didn't know it was naturally
wheel definitely check it out and I know
yeah black coffee a lot of my other
coffee friends say you're not a real
coffee drinker because you don't drink
it black I'm like whatever but yeah
black coffee hard for me I've tried all
right I feel like it's a solution
somewhere here well I've got what I've
got five years at me yeah my I read this
on the other chat but my Zen tea today
tells me that an attitude of gratitude
brings opportunities so I'm pumped I
have a pumpkin spice latte from Jay my
honey tea my vitamin water my protein
shake in in water so what I'm stop omen
yes uh so I am queued up with Jay he's
in he's in the game he's in the house
I'm morrow jungle he's going for mid so
this should be exciting and let's give a
quick tryba to do who we having a chat
we got Zeno's back seam rathered welcome
last minute Louie good morning welcome
guys guilt summer I love it guilt guilt
summer 5 196 is now hosting you what
does that mean Oh extra exposure on the
airstream I appreciate that guilt summer
in 51 96 feeling the love all right all
right well let's uh let's get to some
questions let's do it and let's let's
hope for a victory I had 21 kills
yesterday we couldn't win ah they're not
clad what's Brandon adding in the back
bringing it back I gotta do better
earlier game okay yes that's my
intention hey okay question number one
is okay first question is coming from
shaadi and shoddy
is saying recently joined I recently
joined the company as an outside sales
rep and to be honest it's out of my
comfort zone and it's great the thing is
no one will make a deal with me on the
product that I'm selling I do what my
sales manager says and it's not helping
me I do i do the anyway he's asking a
lot of questions and basically when it
gets to the point where he needs to
close he hesitate and or the people who
whom he wants to sell to our hesitating
and so he's basically asking what's the
best way to approach and to sell
merchant equip merchant equipment sorry
that reading was not great alright so
you know i will say i am personally I
probably myself me to get a lot of
turning on sales because I have not done
sales I personally think that I would be
one of the things that would be hard for
me about sales is like and I know this
isn't true but i would feel like oh you
know I don't want to do because billing
anything because I just let you know
that I care about you so sometimes I
would be I think challenged by sales
because I know there's this aspect of
you need to convince the person to get
what it is that you want to buy or you
want them to buy so that being said evan
has great videos on sales a couple that
I saw were best sales oh I love this
video I had just shot this one out
because this was hilarious definitely
check out the video sales techniques
from the best salesman in the world it
should I remember that was when I for
what Evan that's a good one I liked that
video too yeah that was I think one of
the first videos I saw when I came to
your channel but it's just cool and then
he has you know a top 10 sales
techniques for entrepreneurs so you can
hear from a bunch of famous
entrepreneurs about sales techniques
um so yeah I would I would definitely
start there what do you think of him at
the start of that email did I hear it
right where they said it's out of my
comfort zone and i love it or it's a
good thing that way yeah i think he kind
of likes anything stretched i like it i
like i like the attitude man i like the
mindset going in so many people you know
going outside your comfort zone is scary
and so you're trying to avoid it so I'm
I'm a big fan there um easily merchant
equipment was at it yeah so what I think
of that is when people are doing like
the email the sign of the email the
interac machines and the the kind of
debit machines when you're going out to
merchants like restaurants usually the
smaller stores because the bigger stores
they have big deals with and so Alex
used to be in that business that's what
I recruited him away from to join
Jonathan salsa basically went
door-to-door on restaurants and small
companies and saying hey we've got this
you know debit processing and visa
processing machines do you want to work
with us I think I think when you're
selling a commodity product I'm a big
believer in in core selling and not just
trying to sell the features and benefits
people want to know who you are what you
stand for and that you're gonna you're
gonna you're of the same mindset you
share the same values and they want to
be part of what your business is all
about and then going out and attracting
clients who feel the same way and so now
you're not just your not just selling
the same thing as everybody else like
what's going to happen in this kind of
scenario you know yes there are some
benefits to working with you but it's a
commodity thing man but you're selling a
commodity service just like
just like a financial advisor you know
even real estate agents like yes there's
some difference in the service level i
guess but at the end of the day you're
selling the same product and it's super
hard to stand up one of the examples i
use in the book or you can't see the
book the book set in the twitch stream
this is book that's over here there it
is is of a guy who was a fan a fan of
mine and was a florist and wanted to
stand out is having a hard time selling
flowers it's the same thing you know
you're selling a commodity business
what's the difference between one flower
shop and another flower shop another
flower shop they're mostly exactly the
same and so it gets beaten down on price
right so my roses are a dollar cheaper
than your roses so I'm going to go with
you know you instead and that's the last
game that you want to play and what he's
going to find is as he walks into these
stores it's going to be that same game
where they just beaten him down on price
to try to get the best deal possible and
people can understand how you're
different than everybody else then price
is gonna be the only thing that they
care about price is always part of the
deal but it's it doesn't always have to
be the most important thing and that's
on you to show the difference and so the
flower industry is brutal super price
sensitive one of the most competitive
online businesses as well a lot of the
you know flower shops already have deals
just like this you know a lot of a lot
of the businesses that you're dealing
with already have deals with somebody
else and you got to go displace a
current supplier and get in here oh I'm
not going to buy I'm gonna nut by
potions today I'm going to go with
refillable potion oh can I undo holy
crap sorry I messed up my start to make
good okay whoo talking and playing you
know leads to questionable decisions
sometimes so you know flower industry
you know luxury product wants somebody
you know what's the economy goes
people are buying flowers as much
anymore you know these business that
he's talking to you know there's a tank
in the economy the last thing you want
to do is start investing into more
technology and so I asked him why do you
want to be in the flower business I need
to connect to you somehow because why
would I buy your flowers instead of
somebody else's or worse like not by
anybody just not make a decision at all
on it and he said the flowers make him
calm when he looks at flowers and when
he's around flowers he feels calm that's
why he started getting into the flower
business he just you know he's he gets
stressed out easily and the flowers make
him calm that's great so as one word is
calm what you need to do then is build a
business around calm and so instead of
just being a flower shop you're the
flower shop around calm and so that
impacts every decision that you make in
the business it's it's the flowers that
you pick like pick flowers that make
people feel calm it's the marketing
right when I even for when i look at
your store from the outside it should
make me feel calm right when I walk into
your store it should have a common
impact right how I'm greeted by the
staff should make me feel calm the music
that's playing right the team that you
hire although that makes a big impact on
me as a customer and you want to be a
haven oh we got a kill is that oh such a
what are you playing at yet heimer
you're doing the pantheon experiment
before it all right we've done first
blood it's good mm-hmm so yeah talking
back calm all everything you do should
be a haven for calm people right p.m.
sorry people who want to feel calm
should want to come to your store and
once you start embracing that then he'll
start having more ideal clients wanting
to come and seek him out because now
he's different than everybody else and
people who think that calm is stupid
great like they will never be good
customers for you right they're going to
they're going to just come in buy some
flowers and then go off and do something
else and never be great customers for
you're not going to get along and the
people who love
we'll look at that message and be like
man I wish I found you guys sooner and
they'll be loyal and they'll be willing
to pay more they're not going to be as
price sensitive and so you need to find
what it is that you stand for as a
salesperson as an entrepreneur and bring
that into your business so that you're
not just walking up and randomly
knocking on some businesses door and
just playing the numbers game but you
are able to attract the right partners
to your business to help you market for
you the right customers who are open to
your message and it's not just about
transaction fees if you play that game
you're going to lose so why is this so
interesting for you why why do you like
this challenge why did you sign up for
this you know what's the real benefit
that you're getting from this what's
your why and bring that to your business
consistently you'll start to attract
people who feel the same way and to be
loyal on the refer business to you and
you'll get media attention so that self
discovery process is important and if
you can figure out the core selling part
of it most businesses don't do it most
businesses are just selling features and
benefits and it works but it's
ineffective because as soon as somebody
else has slightly better features of
benefits you know you lose and yes you
still need to have a quality product
right like your thing has to work that's
you know hopefully a given oh wow word
are all our lanes are doing well here
this is great I don't have to do
anything so far we're for now I've done
nothing I might have to start to throw
so that I have an impact late game I
need to have it impact and I'm gonna
have it in fact not satisfied okay hey
um anyway so that would be my advice
that would be my advice sugar what you
staying for and then use that as part of
your your marketing and your approach so
you can start bringing on people clients
who feel your message who would want to
work with you even if your prices were
ten percent higher because they love
what you're
this is all about well I like hearing
the you say this in this context of it
because I I'm familiar with the core
selling in the context of being an
entrepreneur but I like the idea of also
incorporating that into even whatever if
you are a salesperson working for
somebody else you know bringing that
same message yeah and it's a little
trickier working for somebody else
because you know maybe maybe there is no
mission for the company right if you're
the entrepreneur you get to set the
direction in the mission there may not
be a super important values based
mission but that doesn't mean that you
can't be on your own personal mission
like why do you like sales you know what
do you what's the impact that you want
to have on the world you can still have
your own personal mission that hopefully
doesn't doesn't contrast at least with
what your company is doing but you can
always take you could always take
responsibility and do something better
there's always an option to do something
better so don't don't sit there and
blame you know your boss or blame your
business that you can't get to where you
want to go oh alright our next question
comes from Luigi Luigi head yeah Luigi
says i just recently left my job to
focus on entrepreneurship OOP congrats
Congrats he says scary but exciting
after months of testing i just realized
a mobile app on iOS App Store and he
said I wanted to see if I could get your
assistance on next step should be a be
marketed or sold to a giant like
hallmark or papyrus the reviews and the
feedback are very positive like quote
this is genius it's the typical response
yet i'm having five to 10 downloads per
day and only ten percent of those
upgrade to the paid version not to focus
on
the money aspect but in terms of return
at the current place I will likely not
make the investment back my intuition
tells me that the next steps is to sell
to a larger company let me know if you
have any thoughts or if we could discuss
further things all right well um you
know I first of all dis congrats again
for taking the leap and doing a what's
in your heart I think I think I would
want to just add some follow-up
questions about how much do you love
this app and how much are you invested
in it personally I think yesterday you
had a video Evan was talking about
create a business that you wouldn't plan
to to them selves and not not to say
that it's wrong when you do that I mean
it happens all the time but I think I'm
kind of wondering maybe if you want to
ask yourself like how much is this
particular business something that you
are invested in personally it sounds
like the fact that you are already
thinking in your head sell it that this
probably isn't I mean you may really
love this app but it doesn't sound like
it's something that you're invested in
for the long haul so it might be the
right thing to do in that case but uh
yeah I would also just ask you know have
you been in contact with your users are
they why have you gotten any feedback
and is there anything you can do to
improve the performance of the app
because it may be too soon to try to
settle if you haven't made any
adjustment what your users are saying
I'm done can you give me the numbers
again yeah he's saying um five to ten
download the day ten percent of those
are upgrading to the paid version ok so
super interesting so I mean one yes I
agree like you have to you have to be
doing it for the right reasons you have
to you have to have a love for what
you're doing and people who build a
business just trying to sell it often go
broke because they don't have that love
for what they're doing so not
necessarily greatest strategy to start
with oh can I help Jay with this here
yeah we gotta kill that was both mostly
Jay I just cleaned it up um well I'm
gonna see if I can solo dragon here can
I solo the dragon um listen uh ten
percent upgrade is great that's a
phenomenal ratio you know if you're a
look at industry standards you're
probably looking at closer to like one
percent or half a percent so that's
great what you're doing but five to 10
downloads a day is not so if your thing
was so great and everybody loved it
you'd be getting more downloads so the
feedback Oh kills the kills are real I'm
30 he's gonna kill the team the team the
team we're doing work you're doing work
um you need to talk to you use is better
and see like get some better feedback on
how to how to improve you need to like
it's not good enough you're not getting
enough word of mouth five to 10 gallons
a day for our app that is amazing and
great is nowhere close to being enough
if Rishi cup loved your app the world
would know about it right and that's
that's what people do they talk they
talk about things that they like hmm so
your stuff is it good enough
and that's okay but don't fool yourself
and think that you know I'm getting
great feedback so people are loving it
are they using every single day you know
if they're not using it daily then it's
not good enough and you need to tweak it
and improve it and get that feedback you
you you deserve what you get I made this
comment yesterday on my livestream and
actually got a lot of love support which
was not intentional but you know I was
looking at my channel I figured what the
interview was but I 400,000 subscribers
on my channel you know I deserve that in
both a positive and a negative way right
like I put in a lot of work I put in a
lot of effort and so I deserve those
400,000 subscribers but also I'm not at
a million or four million right yeah I
want to be having a bigger impact I
don't deserve that impact yet like the
stuff I'm putting out isn't that good
yet I need to get better I need to
practice more in my gratitude stream
role is saying that I was paper for all
the opportunities to practice like I
still need the money more I am where I
am because of me and what I've done in a
good and a bad contacts I'm not further
ahead because I haven't done enough
right I haven't provided enough value to
be at yeah million subscribers yet and
I'm working on it I want to get there
and some people took that as a evony
doing a great job don't be so hard on
yourself mm-hmm and as I feel the love i
really feel the love that was it was not
the intention to just try to get kind of
you know support from the audience but
hey but it is true and so you are where
you are with your app because it's not
good enough yet you're getting what you
deserve and so instead of you know
another disc complaining but instead of
just sitting back and thinking that the
product is great go out and make it
better so I want people using your app
every day that's how good it has to be
if it's not then it's not good enough
you need to improve and so get as close
as you can to your users talk to them on
the phone if you can you know get them
some in-app you know reward if you can
something to get some feedback so that
you can make this something amazing I'm
just taking some red buff here that's
what I got I'm excited for you yeah nice
to know believe nation wants to step in
and encourage them yeah yeah I think
people felt like I was unduly hard on
myself uh I think people need to be
harder on themselves to write like stop
blaming other things you are where you
are because of you so that sucks but
it's also powerful because you can get
better so go get better boom timo is
foreigner Annie our team is dominating
this is gonna be a fast game in we're 20
and 5 I like it hey what's with the new
skins look at these minions are
different Thanksgiving schemes really it
wait it's us you don't have Thanksgiving
oh maybe halloween alright we have
thanksgiving this is our thanksgiving
weekend here in canada spooky ok ok i
love it would we got next all right we
got next question from belong milani
milani and belong by lanky yeah and he
says a high oven I want to buy my first
car and buy tools to start my small
business what what should I start first
please help yeah interesting well um I
have a couple to follow up questions
because I actually initially thought hey
you
get to get the tools for the business
because the business will help you get
cash flow eventually and get the car but
you also need a car typically to do what
you're doing so if unless you're working
from home and you can do everything from
home and take the bus I don't know that
car might have to be first okay uh i
would say neither ah stop spending money
until you're making money yeah don't
spend money you don't need either you
need your hustle your energy your heart
your drive that's what you need go out
and find a way to make money don't buy a
car when you don't have cash go find a
way to make some money and then invest
in the growth well I think that I think
he I don't know if he doesn't have the
money he might just have the money and
has to choose my car or my tools for my
business but maybe he doesn't have the
money don't ya if you don't have the
money that's the last hash you have you
know if that's the last Kashi you have I
think spending on a car is ridiculous
and if you're gonna spend on the
business then then I hate again I'd like
I hate spending money till I'm making it
stop putting money into a company don't
worry about that yet go find a way to
hustle and make some money without
having to buy the tools or whatever it
is that you need to buy there's a way
there's an easier way to get started do
that and then spend money on the growth
right if you have some clients coming in
listen the J the objective control today
I've been focusing on it i'm pretty
happy but I got every dragon I focus on
my earlier game today guys and it's
working it's working out really well
pretty excited by what's happening here
um so I got sidetracked there but I'm
proud of my performance today
the early game um yeah go find a way to
make some money with your business
without having to buy tools borrow
somebody else's tools you know whatever
there's a way find a way find a way and
then if that's something that you love
doing and is making you money and you
see okay now if like if i invest in my
growth i'm gonna have even more success
that's when you start spending money on
it I wouldn't buy either because
something may happen the economy tanked
you know you may need health care
dollars something right and if that's
your last dollars then I think a car is
a is a terrible investment well what was
here for a scar Evan I don't have a car
I've never had a car I've never owned
the car I still don't right well it's
Toronto like New York you don't need one
I know it's big I mean yes you can get
by without a car um I don't like I don't
know like a car I hate maintenance in
general on anything I hate having a
house I hate having a car so I use
zipcar when I need a car I have a Vespa
to get around when I need to it's good
for most of the year you know three
months off you can it's too cold to
drive around the investment I forgot to
buy the blue is Martin watching this is
gonna be upset I didn't buy the elixir
or a pink ah still so much to improve on
I also must improve on um but yeah I
hate I hate a house and I hate a car but
in general just it's just it whether
it's a car or whether it's you know uh
you know new clothes or something like
it's it's not the best use of your last
dollars that's right you know and yes
clothes are important you know you have
to dress you have to wear stuff but with
your last money like if you're looking
at where I'm going to invest that's
that's what you use when you have money
coming in
so that's it I've never owned the car
I've just realized I've never owned the
car I'd like that client realizes she's
asking the questions yeah honestly like
if I used my phone if I had to get
around that's like you stuck it on the
phone either so another terrible
investment guys don't buy with your last
dollar by your phone yeah there's a lot
that you there's a lot that you've
taught us that you don't need a nice to
have a lot of stuff does a lot of people
get by with a lot less that you don't
need to have stuff if if I need to get
around I would use uber and Zipcars need
a car I don't need a car and if I was
struggling between starting a business
and find a car would I would put my
energy and hustle and whatever I had
into my business but I still ideally i'm
not spending money until i'm making
money with my company so don't do it
either you know what you have that money
invest and guys so that you start making
some with me I want you to start making
money stop focusing on how to spend
money and how you can make money now
invest there you go I love it that one's
on a bit of a rant today yes yeah okay
next question this renekton is really i
don't understand what he's doing anyway
okay yes next guy one of the guys in
their team just keeps wanting to fight
me one-on-one and he doesn't even try to
run away I don't understand it is like
WTF is your damage do pay attention this
is second time oh they they surrendered
our kgg if I'm balloon that's the end of
the game end of the game very sad but
also happy so maybe we shouldn't do the
question though I don't want to why I
don't want to
ggggg all did we all get esas we all got
esas that's crazy oh listen for the
record I got the best ass on the team
but we all got a nice I got it yeah I
got a funny I got a funny comment to
chat from last minute Louie I do what's
up you said some I reached him to be a
belief team sounds like he might need
the car to carry the tool use your feet
to carry the tools borrow a car to carry
the tools take the subway find clients
that are closer there's always another
way there is always another way when you
have paying clients then great go out
and then make tools by tools by the
equipment to help you grow and make it
easier for you but it's not how you
start it's not how you start this is the
first time I realized you're truly a
thien I'm truly a comedian yeah wait
comedian or canadian canadian canadian
Julie Canadian ok what does that mean
I'm Julie Canadian because he is
becoming her DJ for 40 baro baro baro
baro but you say borrow borrow RC baro
baro baro baro maybe borrow I don't want
to say borrow do borrow don't borrow or
borrow money neither ok invest anyway
I'm riled up today round up today guys
hey I don't understand decision-making
sometimes this renekton this guy I was
up against we fought like three times
and he still thinks that he can beat me
and he's like WTF how are people so
confused
I don't understand these are usually
people at with teamed up with I don't
understand it understand I didn't even
have the mallet I've man if I had mallet
it would have just shredded so quickly
anyway we won so xeno can can start the
street count at one yeah street can at
one guy's street count is at one um love
it well we had an insanely long game
yesterday and a pretty fast King today
so it down yeah um Rishi what's the
what's the message what what's the theme
of your thing your your chat later today
it's catching up oh you're so sweet
heaven yeah I just wanted to hang out
it's so funny yesterday Evan was talking
about how you know don't ask me to come
over and just say hi so that's kind of
what we're doing at one o'clock is just
yeah gosh ya know i'm gonna i'm also
going to give some updates on the
channel and you know on my updates cuz
you keep up with what I'm doing pretty
regularly and do some Q&A and and just
kind of connect over a cup of coffee
love it all right one o'clock eastern
cool well what's what's our final
message of the day Rishi what are we
leaving people on today uh well um gosh
I want to I want to think of something
that's actually going to give value here
um I want you to have a cup of don't
give up because truly there is it's
worth it's worth staying in the game I
guess there's a metaphor there with
twitch it's worth it's worth continuing
to persevere and to keep going and so
this weekend yeah whatever you're doing
this weekend for what
to come just know that you can cup of
persevere cup of persevere I like it I
like it cool well thank you guys for
watching I appreciate all the love in
the chat yes we finally got a win it's
exciting to be back on on a high I hope
you guys have an amazing rest of the day
go crush it leading into an awesome
weekend happy thanksgiving for my fellow
Canadians in the stream oh yes we're not
on for Monday yeah monday I have Nina
and Hayden and a whole bunch of fun
stuff so no Monday shenanigans
shenanigans yeah I'll still try to do
the gratitude thing because I didn't
mention anything about that oh okay cool
well thank you guys continue to believe
or whatever your one word is and we'll
see you soon